let me tell you this about ketchup okay
tell me something Japanese about good
it's sweeter in Japan
[Laughter]
[Music]
uh does everybody remember the story of
a dude who survived 24 days at Sea
recently by eating a bunch of ketchup
and stuff no uh I remember about someone
yeah you fell off the ship or something
right and then he uh um this guy his
name's uh Elvis Francois he spent nearly
a month adrift after getting caught in
bad weather with a 47 year old man
surviving uh uh oh and he's a 47 year
old man and he's himself by himself on
only mainly ketchup and spices
um he had like Maggie and some [__]
Jack he's delicious some like salt or
some [__] like that where where was he
off what Coast he was rescued by the
Colombian military
was he um hanging on to something
floating or was he no that was a
different one that's a different one
yeah he was in a boat this guy this guy
became adrift back in December he had
been working on his boat uh in Saint
Martin when he got caught in really bad
weather he wasn't able to sail back to
shore so he had to live on a bottle of
ketchup and other spices
um garlic powder is what the other one
is garlic powder and Maggie stock cubes
he mixed it up with some water and he
had a bottle of one bottle of ketchup uh
and he survived for 24 days 24 24 days
jeez he carved help on the side of his
boat he came back in good shape though
huh lean that's one way to put it super
he's gonna come out with a workout
program The Lost sailor was able to
signal for help using a small pocket
mirror uh and was eventually spotted by
a plane because uh in his final days
around January or something like that he
saw it playing he had a mirror so he's
trying to make signals with it and he
caught a pilot almost crashed this [__]
[Laughter]
laser pointer he goes my eyes [__] you
guys you [__] pranksters
so he was he was finally resting [__]
120 nautical miles away from Porto
Boulevard in the Caribbean on January
16th almost a thousand miles away from
where he started holy [__] Thousand
Miles shortly after that though is that
nautical miles where this goes uh
shortly after that Heinz the ketchup
company ran a huge social media campaign
trying to find him and get in contact
they did this help us hashtag find the
ketchup boat guy right and it got pretty
[__] viral on social media everybody
started like connecting the dots and you
know putting things into place
um and they finally got in touch with
him and the reason why they wanted to
get in touch with them is because they
want to give them a new boat wow I
thought they're gonna ship a bunch of
ketchup and then he would have been done
that would be the worst right [__]
kitchen maybe the [__] worse after
that I wouldn't even stand spend any
time in Sea I'd be trauma I'd be [__]
Trump I'd be like you know I'm moving to
Vegas and then you get lost in the
desert [__] this is why we need [__]
chips my boy doesn't have any location
chips in our skin you know yeah people
would track us down yeah come find me
dude yeah I guess but yeah I just
thought it was really cool that you know
one I think Heinz did a really really
great job with the marketing they like
took uh not advantage of but it was an
opportunity that they like did really
well to hook him up they they did this
hashtag like help us find this guy
because they couldn't get in touch with
him and it like sparked Global Marketing
efforts for them that were better than
like all their marketing campaigns
throughout the entire year they actually
got in touch with them the reason why is
again not to give him ketchup but to
give him a [__] vote
logos all over it with help it just
looks like a big ketchup bottle the
ketchup company is giving him a new boat
what about Maggie what a Maggie off room
nothing huh so you see that's what
that's what it is now you know who's not
a cool company they got a great product
but I thought Maggie was a Chinese
company too because all of my Chinese
friends have Maggie all the time
Maggie's bombers it's it's European
right
it's French I think yeah but with the
fried egg
add some Sriracha a little chili oil
come on and French bread I think um
Maggie is actually wheat sauce it's not
soy sauce yeah yeah that's why they
don't they don't legally put soy sauce
on it they call it seasoning oh that's
all I love it like all the new all the
new labels just say seasoning on it was
it a European method of trying to
recreate soy sauce
because I think that's something similar
to um
Worchester Worchester sauce you know
Worchester sauce yeah Worcestershire
Worcestershire yeah they were trying to
recreate a sauce that they've had like
somewhere else and they're like what the
[__] this is good and then they made
that really
how do you know all this random I
sometimes make up Science and History
makeup facts
it's probably spot on I don't know I'm
kind of right sometimes
you are kind of right you you make it
sound like really
like I believe in [__] you know
so should we keep talking about soy
sauce or ketchup
let's talk about garlic powder ketchup
let me tell you this about ketchup okay
tell me something Japanese about good
it's sweeter in Japan
[Laughter]
um the UK it's sweeter
two that's what you just said about no
but it's Japan because you're Japanese I
just think they copy the UK but then it
in America it's more tomato paste if you
guys had a a condiment or like a sauce
that you wanted to have to survive on
what sauce would you guys like in the
middle of the ocean oh [__] bro
Pepto-Bismol all the way because it
tastes [__] good
oh never mind
if that's the only thing you can drink
you're [__] that's true dude I go
ponzu bro ponzu that's bomb [__] Ponzi
by itself just by itself bro because it
has salt in it right has a little
[__] is it all just lime in there is
there enough nutrition in there probably
not but then when I catch a fish come on
bro oh yeah what am I gonna dip it in
ponzu duh idiots I might do like full-on
like salsa like
pico de gallo yeah
why can't I say Pico the guy who said a
condom
gone in a
day only a lot of people what like
mustard now you're saying straight up
food with salsa it's a sauce yeah that's
kind of like I think salsa literally I'm
a Survivor bolognese
sauce
[Applause]
that [__] will Brown in 30 minutes oh
yeah it won't be good you tell me your
tomatoes are gonna stay [__] cute in
the jar it's a Tostitos Ragu get some
Ragu I'll do it I'll do A1 A1 if you
look at that get mad at him A1 I like a
one that's actually a sauce shut the
[__] up salsa means sauce you said Pico
the guy you need someone chop it up I
said salsa you said
no you said I'm gonna do some actual
salsa I know what that means okay fine
see Jimmy's over here
yeah just admit you're jealous uh yo
y'all know uh logama Logan what is that
oh that's like a Chili Chinese chili
sauce oh like that like a Chili crunch
yeah actually it's not a sauce
but it is so you want to [__] your last
days away
it's just my favorite or your favorite
condiments what's it made of huh what's
it made of it's like a chili oil yeah
chili oil yeah is it that one where you
put sesame oil and chili pepper and it's
nothing but chili pepper seeds and it's
red yeah is that what that is yeah and
you only need a little bit of that one
yeah yeah a little bit good yeah you're
trying to survive off of that we're
talking about like this this is your
meal
what shoes pico de gallo oh yeah I'm
trying to go for some with the new three
years you know
whipped cream sour cream
cheese whiz you don't have a
refrigerator they're just gonna go out
oh does it go bad in a bottle like
unless it's yeah sour cream is milk
[__] think about the most amazing
sauce
dude you're gonna get [__] food
poisoning for Mayo yeah yeah that's just
gonna go bad bro you don't got a fridge
we're gonna refrigerator
oh bro
that [__] goes bad yeah I got food
poison from it but why don't they
refrigerate Mayo at the market then
because you get it and there's [__]
male regular shells when you open it
probably Nah when you open that shit's
made out of vegetable oil and egg
that [__] goes bad bro I'm pretty sure
that [__] goes bad if you leave it out
in the heat that's why I said A1 sauce
it's got salt it's got [__] tomato
and Worcestershire sauce all in one
Worcestershire
where would you go Ryan for sauce uh
queso dip barbecue freaking uh Szechuan
sauce Szechuan the Chick-fil-A ones for
sure
diarrhea what your life away too yeah
I'm trying to read my way back to shore
you're gonna dehydrate yourself so much
faster you need a propulsion element to
get the Boat Moving you guys ever
thought about like being in situations
where you have to survive
like oh if I was here and I was trapped
in the ocean what I would do like you
ever think of those situations all the
time like doomsday prep you think of
that all the time what I watch alone
yeah I'm like these idiots aren't doing
it right now if I was doing it I'd do it
how about when you watch it live I've
never seen that show that's not a show
it's a movie but the guys that they CR
they were in the plane crash and they
had to eat each other yeah all the
soccer players we talked about that and
that's their scenario we said we eat
Bart's butt first remember we we were
Split Decision only because we knew that
he'd be a little muscly man and you
might not die either but we definitely
still would have eaten his butt first
what kind of Chunk you know what I mean
Ubi yeah you should be walking along for
sure I'll just have like honestly if we
just we could keep you alive and
amputate one of your legs and I think
all of us could survive for like two
weeks and that Bart is so objective I
need my legs You're So Pregnant we're
not going nowhere you need your our
survival more than you need your legs
you're so pragmatic that you would be
like yeah this is totally what needs to
happen
yeah this is I'm okay with it you would
do an arm rather than carve out like a
piece of ass I'd rather just do my fast
I'll give you guys my fat yeah all right
I'll cut off cut fast 101 of it with
your get lean program they don't have
any left man yeah dude that's your buff
bar right now
shut the [__] up that part would have
like held us a lot longer yeah this is
skinny bar right now skinny bar it's
like dick yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
foreign